Willow Lake in the Kashmir Valley is
preparing for winter boats like these
are making the last rounds as villagers
extract any remaining water chestnuts
the lake is famous for them and output
has increased over the past two years
this used to be a field There Were Trees
here but after the dredging water
chestnuts started growing back and
livelihoods resumed before that the silt
and marshlands made it hard for us to
sustain Our Lives as dwellers
Himalayas the wooler lake is a critical
source of water in the region and
thousands of people depend on it but in
a matter of decades it shrunk by nearly
half and all because of these willow
trees thousands were planted for
firewood creating mounds of silt that
are choking waterways affecting
vegetation and water quality
restoration projects are underway the
government aims to cut down 2 million
trees by March
subhandar is one of the contractors
I planted hundreds of thousands of trees
for 35 years but it was a mistake it
destroyed the lake the government wants
to restore it and cut down trees this
will bring back the Lake's Glory I feel
very lucky I got the contract
authorities are planting other trees
still barely four of the 90 square
kilometers of lost surface area have
been restored in five years basically
the lake area changes seasonally from
you can say 80 to 50 square kilometers
so it is not necessary that we are we
have to restore whole of the area as a
water body because Wetland has its own
features it has it has to have its mud
flats it has to have its uh solid areas
where birds can stay the lake serves as
a natural barrier against flooding but
environmentalists say pollution levels
need to be controlled for it to be
effective the geomorphic setup of
Kashmir Valley is such that it is prone
to flooding and most of these flood
waters used to find a sinking ground or
a sinkage in involar but if you look at
land system changes that have happened
over the course of last 50 years or five
decades so no there have been
substantial land system changes which
does not allow basically waters flood
waters to sink into our Lake authorities
are planning to store another 23 square
kilometers villagers know it'll take
years for the lake to return to its
former glory but are happy with the
first signs of Revival Al Jazeera